hallo und willkommen zu zdf heute live
in letzter zeit gibt es immer wieder
berichte über feuer und anschläge in
russland jetzt könnte man sagen in so
einem riesigen land ist das an sich
nichts besonderes aber die fälle häufen
sich seit dem russland die ukraine
angegriffen hat sind es zufälle oder ist
es sabotage
darüber wollen wörter abend sprechen mit
einer investigativ journalist in einer
russischen und mit dem russland experten
und blogger nico lange sie und ihr könnt
uns fragen schicken die posse die am
besten in die chats oder ihr schickt sie
uns per mail meine kollegin nina
niebergall hat erstmal die jüngsten
vorfälle zusammengefasst
normalerweise melden sich hier
wehrdienstleistende und rekruten zu
dienst eine militäreinrichtung in
nischni über tops keine großstadt mitten
in russland genau das will dieser
brandstifter offenbar verhindern das
video wird bei youtube geteilt
mutwillige zerstörung oder eine form des
protests
die aktion ist laut einer recherche
russischer journalist innen kein
einzelfall das investigativ magazin die
insider zählt 23 attacken auf
einberufung center meist brandanschläge
mit selbst gebastelten molotow-cocktails
wir konnten die echtheit der videos
verifizieren es könnte sogar noch mehr
solcher anschläge gegeben haben denn
seit kriegsbeginn gibt es immer wieder
meldungen über mysteriöse brände wie
hier in einem chemiewerk nahe moskau die
hintergründe unklar hier begann die
brandserie ein forschungsinstitut der
luft und raumfahrt verteidigungskräfte
brennt entweder ein ort 180 kilometer
von moskau entfernt manche der feuer
sind in grenznähe und damit in
reichweite ukrainischer waffen es könnte
sich theoretisch um ukrainische angriffe
handeln manche aber sind viel zu weit
weg
und dann entgleisen seit kriegsbeginn
auffällig viele züge in russland laut
die insider 63 zwischen märz und juni
fast anderthalb mal so viele wie im
vergangenen jahr die russischen behörden
sagen technische fehler das investigativ
magazin sagt sabotage im netz rufen
aktivisten dazu auf gleise zu
manipulieren die fotos landen etwa auf
dem telegramm kanal mit dem titel stoppt
die waggons das ziel die panzer die in
die ukraine transportiert werden
aufzuhalten militanter protest in einem
land in dem es eigentlich gar keinen
protest mehr geben darf
und wir sprechen jetzt mit alisa zum
lanz kaya vom investigativ magazin die
insider sie kommt aus russland lebt
mittlerweile im ausland wir treffen sie
heute abend in warschau so viel können
wir sagen sie möchte aus
sicherheitsgründen nicht erkannt werden
und alisa ist natürlich ein pseudonym
hallo alisa guten abend
guten abend sie haben zu diesen
vorfällen eine story veröffentlicht das
haben wir gerade schon gesagt was genau
haben sie herausgefunden
uns hat es interessiert
als wir gesehen haben
dass irgendwelche kanäle geschaffen
wurden um die waggons in den westen zu
stoppen
das hat uns sehr interessiert weil es
handelte sich um die waggons mit panzern
militärfahrzeugen oder irgendwelchen
anderen
militärtechnik die über die die
russische föderation verfügt die sich in
der ukraine befindet und einige menschen
haben die verantwortung übernommen für
diese vorfälle
natürlich konnte man denen nicht aufs
wort glauben weil früher kam es zu
solchen vorfällen nicht in den letzten
20 jahren
ich meine damit vorfälle die solche
sabotage gruppen organisiert haben im
prinzip solcher art proteste gab es
nicht jegliche form der proteste war
sehr stark sanktioniert und deswegen gab
es diese proteste gar nicht vorher um
diese quellen irgendwie zu prüfen um
auch den effekt
dieser mitteilungen von diesen menschen
zu prüfen diese aktionen die sie
angeblich gemacht haben habe ich mich an
die quellen gewand an die
informationsquellen und habe gefragt was
ist denn überhaupt passiert was
interessant ist die werden überhaupt
nicht veröffentlicht solche daten
seitens der russischen föderation
nicht desto trotz ist es klar dass die
behörden irgendwelche press release doch
veröffentlichen oder die örtlichen
regionalen zeitungen geben irgendetwas
preis und wenn ich das alles in den
letzten jahren gesammelt habe habe ich
verstanden dass tatsächlich in diesem
jahr dem anfang des einmarsches
russlands in die ukraine haben die
zelle diese entgleisungen sehr stark
zugenommen rund 40 prozent mehr in
diesem jahr gibt es diese fälle im
vergleich zu den vorherigen volk vorigen
jahr die geografie dieser fälle hat sich
auch verändert früher waren die meistens
auf dem territorium von fabriken in
sibirien oder im ural und gerade dort
gab es diese vorfälle
arbeiten ja mittlerweile aus dem ausland
sie müssen aus dem ausland
herausarbeiten ich stelle mir das
ziemlich schwierig vor wie konnten sie
sicherstellen dass ihre quellen dann
auch glaubwürdig sind über diese distanz
die klar haft ich kyte ist sehr leicht
zu prüfen weil
selbst wenn es keinen register dazu gibt
die behörden führen kein vergleichbares
register und die sagen es kommt nichts
außergewöhnliches vor auch wenn die
regionalen zeitungen
dem widersprechen
und nicht desto trotz die
polizeibehörden zum beispiel die müssen
so was melden wenn die züge zb
entgleisen und wenn ich das analysiert
habe das was in diesem jahr gefahren
war und die zahl solcher vorfälle im
letzten jahr so gab es einen sehr
starken anstieg
eben im schienenverkehr weil ich weiß
dass
diese daten in russland die
werden auf jeden fall von der polizei
die müssen von der polizei gemeldet
werden
wer sind denn diese menschen
so
wie es verstanden haben
dass diese partisanen wie sie auch in
russland genannt werden die partisanen
werden im russischen
in der geschichte mit dem zweiten
weltkrieg assoziiert und
diese
dieses wort partisan ist sehr stark denn
es heißt dass die partisanen eine sehr
großen beitrag geleistet haben
im zweiten weltkrieg diese menschen
bezeichnet sich eben als partisan und
als es bekannt wurde dass diese menschen
eben im schienenverkehr tätig sind
sozusagen ich habe versucht mit denen in
kontakt zu treten
über verschiedene kanäle über proxy über
meine vertraute personen und es waren
menschen die einen sehr
unterschiedlichem background haben zum
beispiel viele von denen haben sich noch
vor dem krieg
ein
anarchisten und kommunisten sie haben
sich an die angeschlossenen die haben
aber irgendwie einen ideologischen krieg
geführt so zu sagen aber mit dem
einmarsch russlands in die ukraine
glaube ich haben sie verstanden die
haben nichts mehr zu verlieren weil du
kannst jetzt sowohl für sabotage als
auch für ein post bei twitter oder
facebook genau so eingekerkert sein
deswegen haben sie zu diesen schädlichen
maßnahmen gegriffen einige sind von
denen überzeugt dass dieser schienen
krieg zb die haben den sich von den
vielen russen abgeschaut die haben auf
diese weise noch 20 21 gegen lukaschenko
damit angekämpft und die menschen in
belarus haben so eine strömung
geschaffen da gibt es verschiedene
menschen mit ideologien oder auch ohne
die haben ein system
entwickeln wie man einen sabotage
protest überhaupt durchführen kann und
bestimmte reaktionen auf diese
machenschaften sie zum beispiel
lukaschenko drauf reagiert hat die
wollen damit wollten damit zeigen dass
lukaschenko im inneren des landes keine
unterstützung findet und die güterzüge
zum beispiel die können auch irgendwie
sich verspäten oder irgendwie
verschwinden es gab diesen schienen
krieg bereits in belarus und
zurückgegriffen auf diese diesem krieg
in russland hat diese bewegung an fahrt
genommen und es man kann jetzt sprechen
die
hauptidee dieser strömung ist diese
waggons zu stoppen diese militär waggons
mit
militärfahrzeugen mit unterstützung für
die russische armee zu stoppen weil die
menschen sind davon überzeugt dass
dieser krieg absolut unrechtmäßig ist
und das kann weiter so nicht gehen das
ist im großen und ganzen
so gewesen ich habe das glück gehabt
solche menschen zu kontaktieren mit
denen in kontakt zu treten um zu
verstehen wie die handeln und es hat
sich herausgestellt dass ein teil von
denen sind sogenannte an nach
kommunisten aber viele von denen haben
überhaupt keine ideologie wenn nicht
alle die haben auch keine speziellen
kenntnisse die wurden nicht speziell
geschult die roten nicht speziell
dafür
irgendwie an gelernt das sind einfach
nur menschen die miteinander
verschiedene arten
teilen wie man irgendwie dem
schienenverkehr einen schaden zufügen
kann so dass diese züge gestoppt werden
können zum beispiel in der letzten woche
gab es einen fall da ist
sind mehr als 15 waggons entgleist und
ungefähr
200 meter an schienen wurden beschädigt
und es war sehr wichtig denn um so was
wieder aufzubauen das braucht zeit und
diese zellen die sich gebildet haben
sie sind überhaupt nicht
spezialisiert oder
angeworben es ist so eine strömung die
bereits bekannt ist aber die zeigt
einfach nur dass es die gibt das ist zb
telegramm kanäle die anti kriegs
thematik haben aber die kommunizieren
nicht unbedingt miteinander tische
menschen einige die
ideologisch verstärkt sind manche von
denen kommunizieren miteinander aber sie
verweisen darauf dass man keine
persönlichen daten
hinterlassen dürfte so dass andere weil
man einfach nur den anderen menschen
auch vor ort nicht immer vertrauen darf
und nicht es gibt nicht viele die zu
solchen protesten bereits sind auf diese
weise
habe ich gesehen dass es ein
dezentralisiertes netzwerk gibt und das
was die vereint in ganz russland und
jeder kann dieser strömung beitreten es
gibt es ist aber keine zentralisierte
strömung und eben das
dank dieser dezentralisierung sind sie
besser geschützt sie können mehr leute
anwerben
das unterschiedliche gruppierungen haben
wir aber im prinzip ein gemeinsames ziel
haben ich würde gerne nochmal sie haben
das erklärt mit den anschlägen auf die
bahnschienen ich würde gerne nochmal auf
diese attacken auf die einberufung
center zurückkommen vielleicht ganz kurz
sehen sie da unterschiede
wenn man im ganzen darüber spricht dann
ist es ein neues phänomen für den
russischen protest weil in den letzten
15 jahren gab es nichts dergleichen
ich wiederhole mich selbst ganz
friedliche formen von protesten hat es
zum beispiel wenn man auf die straße
raus geht oder wenn einzelpersonen
irgendwie auf die straße gegangen sind
die wurden sehr stark
sanktioniert und
selbst wenn man einmal auf die straße
gehen das war sehr gefährlich weil man
drei mal auf die straße gegangen ist
dann wo der mann verlange es zeit
eingesperrt und noch mehr radikale
maßnahmen gab es nicht in den letzten
jahren gab es in russland so was nicht
nichts vergleichbares deswegen als
phänomen als eine form der macht
proteste zum beispiel wenn ein gleis
dermaßen beschädigt wird dass die
waggons die
militärausrüstung nicht mehr
transportieren können oder wenn man
diese einberufung zentren in brand setzt
so werden diese maßnahmen dazu
man greift zu diesen maßnahmen eben um
den widerstand irgendwie zu zeigen dass
nicht jeder damit einverstanden ist und
weil es
gibt sehr wenige menschen die
tatsächlich
zur armee wollen zurzeit in russland
oder die verträge unterschreiben sollen
mit der russischen an die menschen
greifen diese einberufung zentren
erstens weil sie nicht einberufen werden
wollen und weil sie den widerstand gegen
den krieg in der ukraine zeigen wollen
eine der gruppen die sehr viele solcher
brandstiftungen
motiviert hat die gruppe hat dazu
aufgerufen
es gab dass es handelte sich um eine
radikale nationalistische bewegung sie
konnte das machen weil sie über ein
netzwerk verfügt hat weil sie bereits
jahrelange erfahrung
im aufbau des netzwerkes verfügte und
sie konnten entweder
molotow cocktails
dafür bauen sie verfügten über
informationen über die erfahrungen die
haben andere menschen dazu aufgerufen
aber bei solchen brand setzen haben sich
auch menschen beteiligten überhaupt
keinen hintergrund so irgendwelche
ideologie gehabt haben es gab auch
freiwillige
sich als freiwillige entpuppt haben die
wollten auf diese weise hier gilt wie
auch der russischen armee helfen und es
gibt menschen die damit nicht
einverstanden sind sie stehen solche
aktivisten auf menschen die den
russischen
militärs helfen und auf diese weise
wollen sie die verhindern die setzten
auch ihre fahrzeuge in brand ich hatte
glück einige solchen menschen zu
kontaktieren und
natürlich wusste ich dass es keine
massenhafte ideologie dahinter steckt
wird man das mal kurz fragen die andere
perspektive die ihnen die russischen
behörden mit diesem
sabotageakten um gibt es da eine gewisse
transparenz oder wird das alles unter
den teppich gekehrt
darüber wird er gar nicht gesprochen
und so sieht es auch in den fällen wenn
an der grenze zur ukraine irgendetwas
vorfeld wenn irgendwelche raketen oder
drohnen militär drohnen in brands zum
beispiel zu sehen sind oder im kurs zu
sehen sind die behörden sagen manchmal
etwas das so aber meistens sagen sie es
ist nichts passiert manchmal sehen wie
reaktionen von bestimmten regional
machthabern wenn sie sagen hier wurde
irgendwas in brand gesetzt und mehr
informationen kommen gar nicht durch es
wird überhaupt nicht
weiter darüber berichtet wenn wir über
die züge sprechen dann ist der grünste
meistens es war zu heiß die gleise sind
breiter geworden und deswegen ist der
zug entgleist oder einfach nur der
verschleiß aber dagegen spricht die
statistik selbst weil
es diese in dieser verschleiß der ist
auf einmal sehr stark geworden und bei
wenn wir manche fälle als beispiel
nehmen wenn die bewirken meinten es ist
passiert weil es sehr wegen der sehr
hohen temperaturen zu haben wir
informationen die dafür sagen dass uns
gerade in diesem dieser region menschen
gab die zu solchen anschlägen bereit
waren alisa ich habe ja im vorgespräch
erzählt dass wir einen stream sind in
dem auch unsere userinnen und user
fragen stellen können und da möchte ich
ihnen jetzt was daraus vorlesen oscar
fragt auf youtube erst mal sagt er
heftig wie mutig würde mich mal
interessieren um welchen faktor ihrer
meinung nach die jungen menschen es
schaffen transporte von kriegs gütern zu
sabotieren oder zu verzögern haben sie
dazu informationen
es gibt bestimmte methoden die
die bestimmte techniken die mit solchen
störungen der des schienenersatzverkehrs
zu tun haben dass man zum beispiel eine
verzögerung verursacht oder eben wenn
man diese
schränke auch beschädigt über die
signale an kommen bis zu der physischen
zerstörung der gleise oder einige
fragmente der gleise und das ist das was
die partisanen zum beispiel in belarus
bereits 43 und 44 gemacht haben während
des zweiten weltkrieges in diesem sinne
sind malte methoden sogar ähnlich manche
technologien die etwas modernen sind in
den letzten 70 jahren hat sich einiges
geändert und natürlich gibt es weniger
riskante methoden aber manche dinge
technologien werden eins zu eins aus dem
zweiten weltkrieg
angewendet wenn ich noch mal zurück zum
zweiten weltkrieg komme so wurden sehr
viele
eisen brücken
zerstört jetzt gibt es so was er weniger
aber
nicht ganz verständlich gibt sind die
aktionen die an der grenze zur ukraine
anscheinend
anscheinend passiert sind bisher habe
ich
tatsächlich auch eine diskussion in
unserem chat da gibt es
menschen die sagen und wie michael auf
youtube der ist dafür der sagt die haben
echt eier das sagt man hier in
deutschland so bei den drakonischen
strafen die dort auf die menschen warten
wenn sie erwischt werden es gibt aber
auch kritische stimmen von maclife auf
youtube der sagt genau einfach mal die
gleise sabotieren bis auch mal ein zug
mit zivilisten entgleist großes kino
hier ganz großes kino also ist das so
dass auch personenzüge angegriffen
werden dass wir das vielleicht noch mal
klarstellen ich
möchte betonen dass ich einfach noch
eine journalistin bin ich beteilige mich
an diesem prozess nicht ich
überprüfe es was die menschen oft voran
geht es gab es jetzt noch keinen
einzigen menschen der dadurch zu schaden
gekommen ist und ich möchte darauf
betonen dass die menschen die es machen
als ziel haben sie als oberes ziel
gesetzt das kein leben zerstört wird es
die ziele nur auf die güterzüge es gab
keinen personenzug der entgleist ist in
diesem zeitraum wie es auch früher war
dass es erstens und zweitens
was die männchen opfer angeht ich möchte
auch sagen dass manche
teilnehmer dieser netzwerke die
befürchten dass diese sabotage akte auch
irgendwie
irgendwie auch benutzt werden dafür dass
die regierung selbst so ein sabotageakt
macht und die saboteure daran auch mit
natürlich mit menschenopfer die werden
die saboteure eben daran besichtigen
warum gibt es solche befürchtungen
es gibt bereits rhetorik in russland
darüber dass die vorfälle ende der 90er
und anfang 2000 jahre es gibt diese
rhetorik den menschen sagen dass diese
vorfälle
gerade von der ruhm den russischen
machthabern gesteuert wurde und zb
sprechen wir über
den vorfall in russland in einem bezirk
von moskau und da
waren einige häuser
explodiert und mann hieß es hieß diese
terroristen haben das gemacht und
meistens waren dass china die
terroristen es gibt aber informationen
dass das passiert ist
weil
viele säcke mit
lebensmitteln angeblichen angeblichen
lebensmittel hinein geführt wurden und
die menschen haben diese
lebensmittel gar nicht beachtet es gibt
aber andere versionen die darüber
sprechen dass eben dir das russische fsb
dafür verantwortlich ist damit die
situation die politische situation sich
in russland zuspitzt soll dass die macht
so dass die menschen an dem acht norm
noch mehr davon bekommen ich würde ihnen
ja nur noch eine letzte frage stellen
die auch aus dem chat kommt von michael
er fragt ob wir die frage stellen ob es
oft dauer ein kollektives erwachen unter
den bürgern der russischen bevölkerung
geben könnte und wenn ja was müsste
dafür geschehen was denken sie alisa
diese frage die beschäftigt sehr viele
menschen und ich als journalistin kann
diese frage nicht beantworten ich meine
jedoch dazu dass der wille war
insgesamt das verständnis
dass dessen dass sie prägen die macht
sein können in den letzten 20 jahren
ist dieses verständnis zerstört worden
und das ist der rote faden von putins
politik in den letzten 20 jahren
deswegen möchte ich es natürlich glauben
dass immer mehr menschen sich in der
situation sehen dass sie können und
bereit sind gegen diese sachlage zu
protestieren denn die menschen in
russland die sie leben in not eigentlich
ich
kann ihnen nur aus eigener erfahrung
sagen das ist alles passiert weil putin
das gezielt gesteuert hat der putin
mainz wenn du arm bist dann stellst du
dir keine politik fragen dann
interessierst du dich nicht an
irgendetwas anderes interessiert nicht
nur wie du dich ernähren kannst deine
familie ernähren
kannst und wurde wohnen kannst und das
ist die basis dieser macht parameter die
aufgebaut hat die menschen sehen diese
fragen nicht mehr weil sie mit anderen
fragen beschäftigt sind dieser
angezettelten krieg der wird jetzt auf
dem rücken von menschen ausgetragen die
action-serie alarm sind und ich glaube
irgendwann wird es so irgendetwas führen
zu einem verständnis der menschen auch
der nationalitäten der menschen die in
russland leben die auch sehr stark in
den letzten zwanzig jahre unterdrückt
wurde vielleicht auch diese menschen
gewinnen jetzt an verständnis dafür dass
die leute die jetzt in der ukraine
fallen es ist meistens keine russen es
sind vertreter anderer
nationen die zu den ärmsten regionen
russlands zählen deswegen kann es zu
einer nationalen
selbstverständnis führen ich glaube
solche aspekte wenn die menschen sich
überhaupt nicht für die politik
interessieren und auch keine idee kommen
gegen die macht
etwas zu machen
ich glaube das war anfangs so aufgebaut
damit überhaupt nicht mal jemand über
irgendwelche pro texte
vorlesen er schreibt alisa ist eine sehr
mutige frau ich wünsche ihnen sehr viel
kraft und glück auf ihrem weiteren weg
und ich möchte mich auch ganz herzlich
bei ihnen bedanken dass sie bereit waren
mit uns zu sprechen vielen dank frau aus
dem landkreis
über vielen dank
ja und damit gehen wir direkt weiter zum
russland experten und blogger nico lange
guten abend herr
lange ihr fokus liegt auf außen
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik um
sie mal kurz vor zu stellen sie haben
außerdem unter anderem in kiew gelebt
und gearbeitet und in sankt petersburg
wenn sie hören was die journalisten eben
erzählt hat wovon gehen sie aus nimmt
der kreml diese ganzen vorfälle ernst
wenn man muss davon ausgehen dass der
kreml jeden vorfall ernst nimmt putin
hat und das ist ja eben deutlich
geworden in den letzten mehr als 20
jahren ein system der unterdrückung
aufgebaut
und schon vor einigen jahren ist ja
aufgefallen dass jede noch so kleine
demonstration und ist ein paar ältere
damen sind die gegen schlechte
wasserleitung demonstrieren direkt von
der russischen polizei sehr hart
angegangen werden putin fühlt sich nicht
sicher als diktator und die hat angst
davor dass irgendeine art von protest
fahrt aufnimmt und eine welle entwickelt
und er hat in der ukraine aber auch in
georgien in belarus die erfahrung
gemacht wenn man proteste nicht
rechtzeitig stoppt dann entwickeln sie
sich zu einer welle die möglicherweise
nicht mehr aufzuhalten sind also ja man
kann davon ausgehen dass gut in unseren
regime diese proteste sehr ernst nehmen
sie sagen es russland hat mit beginn des
krieges jegliche form des protests
unterdrückt und auch schon in den jahren
zuvor aber jetzt schauen wir mal noch
mal seit februar elisa miebach fasst
zusammen
seit dem angriff auf die ukraine gibt es
auch in russland selbst widerstand gegen
den krieg wie hier in sankt petersburg
und moskau protestieren schon am 24
februar dem tag des einmarsches tausende
menschen in mehr als 40 städten
1700 werden festgenommen
wegen ihrer berichte über den krieg
werden der online tv sender durch und
der radiosender echo moskwy am ersten
märz gesperrt sie waren zwei der letzten
unabhängigen medien im land
jegliche sogenannte falsche
informationen über die russische armee
verbietet das parlament am 4 märz per
gesetz auch für proteste gegen dem krieg
drohen jetzt bis zu 15 jahre haft der
zugang zu mehreren sozialen netzwerken
und einigen ausländischen medien wird
flock ihren
höhepunkt erreichten die proteste am
sechsten märz an nur einem tag werden
4600 demonstrierende in russland
verhaftet
die bilder von marina aus jan ecowas
plakat gehen am 14 märz um die welt die
journalisten protestiert im russischen
staatsfernsehen gegen den krieg die
folge eine geldstrafe inzwischen hat sie
das land verlassen
am achten april schließt die russische
regierung die büros zahlreicher ngo
darunter amnesty international human
rights watch und auch parteinahe
deutsche stiftungen
trotz drohender strafen immer wieder
vereinzelte proteste im ganzen land wie
hier am 16 april in rabat
zwanzigster mainz krieg rufen fans der
band kiss kiss auf einem konzert in
sankt petersburg die aktion verbreitet
sich schnell in den sozialen netzwerken
die proteste im land verlagern sich auch
wegen der harten strafen mehr und mehr
in den untergrund viele kritiker des
regimes wandern aus
alexej kudrin of ist geblieben am 8 juli
wird der kommunalpolitik hat zu sieben
jahren straflager verurteilt er ist der
erste der wegen des neuen gesetzes gegen
die falschinformationen über die
russischen streitkräfte verurteilt wird
weil er öffentlich das verbotene wort
krieg ausgesprochen hat noch im
gerichtssaal fragt er brauchte immer
noch diesen krieg
bis heute sind im zusammenhang mit dem
ukraine krieg mehr als 16.000 menschen
festgenommen worden berichtet die
menschenrechtsorganisation cofadeh info
also wir sehen zu beginn waren diese
proteste friedlich warum jetzt in
letzter zeit dieser radikalisierung
also zum nächsten mal für mich ist
wichtig dass sie darüber berichten und
dass ich auch die namen der menschen die
mutig in russland demonstrieren nennen
das ist glaube ich etwas das wir hier
leisten können den namen immer wieder
aufzurufen und danach zu fragen wo sie
und was mit ihnen geschieht die proteste
haben sich verändert denn punkte das
muss man glaube ich ganz nüchtern so
konstatieren war darauf vorbereitet und
hat so etwas wie einen zweifrontenkrieg
bekommen er ist in der ukraine
einmarschiert und hat gleichzeitig sehr
sorgfältig nach geschaut wer
demonstriert eigentlich gegen den krieg
in russland wir sind die anführer von
protesten wer traut sich und hat dann
diese leute verfolgt und bestraft
eingesperrt oder mit repression versehen
manche dieser repression bekommen wir ja
auch gar nicht mit die leute bekommen
komische anrufe werden auf dem
arbeitsplatz unter druck gesetzt oder
die familie wird eingeschüchtert diese
dinge passieren aber und das geht ja bis
dahin dass die menschen die weiter
protestieren wollen und immer nach neuen
formen suchen und versuchen vielleicht
auch die gesetze ein bisschen suchen
gehen sogar dafür verhaftet werden wenn
sie sagen kein krieg oder dafür dass sie
das mehrfach geschehen ist einfach mit
einem weißen blatt papier
demonstrieren
und gleichzeitig sieht man wenn menschen
häufig sind es auch einzelne person so
mutig sind sich auf die straße zu
stellen in russischen städten
das häufig andere menschen vorbei den
ihnen gratulieren ihnen kurz auf die
schulter klopfen und sie unterstützen
das heißt es gibt schon viele menschen
in russland die mit dem krieg nicht
einverstanden sind die aber nicht wissen
wie es in diesen protest äußern können
ohne harte repression zu erhalten
insofern aber auch eine entwicklung die
glaube ich nachvollziehen
wenn es keine form des protests liebt
die mehr möglich sind dann geht der
prozess in den untergrund er sucht sich
neue wege und ich würde auch viele der
anschläge gegen einberufung center oder
gegen bahngleise daran einordnen dass
leute die nicht einfach stunden standen
sind jetzt neue wege des protest zu
dem er eben erfahren dass die
gruppierungen sehr unterschiedlich sind
das hat alicia erzählt und die
beweggründe gegen diesen krieg zu sein
sind es auch kann trotzdem aus ihrer
sicht eine breite bewegung entstehen die
putin gefährlich werden könnte oder
ähnliche frage von motor auf youtube ist
russland weil ich bereit für eine
revolution
naja ich glaube
protestbewegung in diktaturen wie
russland eine ist sind immer
sammlungsbewegung von sehr
unterschiedlichen personen das war
übrigens bei der friedlichen revolution
in der ddr auch so und auch in anderen
vergleichbaren situation sehr viele
unterschiedliche menschen und ich habe
ja gerade gesagt es gibt wenig
möglichkeiten um missfallen zum ausdruck
zu bringen und viele russen konnten ja
vor dem krieg wenigstens noch mal ein
paar wochen im sommer irgendwohin reisen
im westen im westen etwas freier atmen
vielleicht auch einen anderen lebensstil
wie im wenigstens für ein paar wochen
nicht mal das ist mir möglich sie sind
eingesperrt und sie haben das gefühl
putin hat russland komplett ins abseits
geführt und sie haben keine perspektive
in der zivilisierten welt und ich glaube
so kommt es dass ganz viele
unterschiedliche menschen zusammenkommt
die zunächst einmal darin gipfelt dass
wir diesen krieg gegen die ukraine und
dem ukrainischen menschen nicht wollen
und dass sie das repressions verschieben
von putin das jetzt seit über 20 jahren
russland einengt dass sie das ablehnen
sollte es sich weiterentwickeln in den
protesten wird man sicherlich darüber
reden welche unterschiedlichen ansichten
es in diesem programm auch gibt aber
zunächst einmal ist eine
sammlungsbewegung
ich würde gern noch mal auf die rolle
der medien zu sprechen kommen und zwar
stellte roland roland treibt erstmal
respekt für diese wunderbaren jungen
menschen die für die wahrheit ihr leben
riskieren er schreibt aber auch solange
die medien in putins hand sind wird sich
an der meinung der masse nichts ändern
wie sehen sie das
ja das stimmt
die russische propaganda ist sehr
mächtig und putin kann dadurch dass er
team setzt oder einfach von themen
ablenkt oder einfach das thema wechselt
sehr schlag die agenda bestimmen
man darf aber die russen dass das
betrifft auch nicht unterschätzen wenn
man sieht wie stark die nutzung von bpm
netzwerken gestiegen ist seit die zensur
zugeschlagen hat in russland wenn man
sieht wie die russen sich im internet
umschauen und bestimmte reaktionen
aussieht vom russischen menschen dann
kann man schon davon ausgehen dass im
ausland heimlich still und leise
mit gekommen was tatsächlich passiert
und auch auf diese nachrichten die
außerhalb der russischen propaganda sind
reagieren können und auch
vielleicht dazu noch mal eine andere
frage von chris auf youtube wo
organisieren sich die gegner des kriegs
im internet spielen plattformen wie
telegramm eine rolle oder werden nur
russische plattformen genutzt
wird eine sehr wichtige rolle in
russland weil der inhaber paragraf
selbst einmal verfolgt worden ist vom
russischen staat und ist abgelehnt hat
im gegensatz zu den meisten anderen
internet service anbietern in russland
abgelehnt hat mit den
sicherheitsbehörden zusammen zu arbeiten
er lebt ja auch schon lange nicht mehr
in russland aber telegramm hat deswegen
den ruf die daten nicht preiszugeben und
vieles sowohl der putin propaganda auf
der berichterstattung über den krieg
aber eben auch der organisation der
proteste in russland findet auf dem berg
statt im übrigen ist elvira mauch glaube
ich der kanal wo die meisten russen
ungefilterte informationen kriegen über
den verlauf des krieges in der ukraine
über die grausamkeiten die dort
vielleicht noch eine frage von peter auf
facebook sehr gute informationen aber
leider wird sich in nächster zeit nichts
ändern bis putin weg ist und ob es
danach besser wird daran hat er seine
zweifel was könnte denn einen danach
sein wie könnte denn ein danach aussehen
zunächst einmal ist es doch wichtig dass
wir genau hinschauen und dass wir nicht
die politische propaganda glauben
ausland her eine blackbox und alle
suchen die ihn unterstützen und wir
könnten nicht genau wissen muss dahin
vor sich gehen oder wir würden russland
nicht verstehen man kann sehen dass es
im ausland sehr unterschiedliche
personen gibt es die personen die putin
unterstützen es gibt sicherlich auch
viele lehnen das gleichgültig ist und es
gibt eben auch widerstand gegen putin es
zunächst einmal wichtig da genau
hinzuschauen und das zur kenntnis zu
nehmen die frage wie sich russland
weiter entwickelt ist im moment sehr
schwer zu beantworten putin hat sich mit
diesen krieg in ein abenteuer gestürzt
und ich glaube vielen russen selbst
denen die putin unterstützen wird klar
dass die erzählung man könnte da ganz
schnell gegen die ukraine siegen oder
die ukraine von der landkarte entfernen
wie das ja von putin und medwedew unter
anderem gesagt wird dass diese dinge
eben nicht so leicht erreichbar sind und
dass russland schwierigkeiten hat das
viele tausende junge russische soldaten
fallen in der ukraine und das brüssel
und dennoch militärisch eigentlich gar
nicht mehr voran kommt und ich glaube
dass zusammen mit den protesten hat ein
potenzial um den gewaltigen druck zu
entwickeln in der russischen
gesellschaft
das wird glaube ich sehr stark davon
abhängen wie dieser krieg weiter
verläuft wie es mit punkten und mit
russland weiter geld da ist es jetzt für
prognosen zufrieden wir haben heute so
viele spannende fragen unserer userinnen
und user im chat eine muss ich ihnen
noch stellen mindestens chris schreibt
denn sie haben es ja gerade gesagt sie
haben die das militär gerade
angesprochen wie steht es bei der
russischen armee es gab gerüchte zu
beginn des krieges von sabotageakten in
den eigenen reihen
ja es gab soldaten die reigen technik
unbrauchbar gemacht haben es gab sogar
die sich selbst verletzt haben damit sie
nicht kämpfen müssen das gibt es aber
gleichzeitig gibt es ein ganz brutaler
und hartes und menschenfeindliches nicht
der kontrolle und das unter druck setzen
von den jungen leuten so dass sie
meistens gar keine wahl haben als
nach vorne zu marschieren es gibt aber
viele russische soldaten die
streitkräfte verlassen wollen und putin
hat gerade große problem dass wir eine
gigantische gehälter über 5000 euro im
monat das ist für russland unvorstellbar
viel werden angeboten damit junge leute
zu den streitkräften gehen und in der
ukraine kämpfen und selbst das hilft
mich also ich glaube da gibt es im
militär ganz viel widerstand und
an der spitze des militärs gibt es viele
die mit dem check listen also mit den
geheimdiensten zudem putin zählt die
viele institutionen in russland
kontrollieren
unzufrieden sind weil viele militärs
auch führende generäle der auffassung
sind putin und seine geheimdienstler
haben diesen sinnlosen krieg angezettelt
obwohl wir nicht zu gewinnen ist und die
militärs müssen ist jetzt ausbaden da
gibt es sicherlich ein potenzial denn je
nachdem wie der krieg weiter verläuft
dass der weitere proteste zum ausdruck
kommen wenn mir noch mal auf die
anschläge zurück kommen da gibt es eine
frage von vielen verändern die anschläge
schlossen dass russland aufhört zu töten
in welche richtung werden diese
verändert
zunächst einmal das hat ja die
journalistin sehr eindrucksvoll
berichtet sind diese anschläge sehr
sichtbar wenn ein zug entgleist bekommen
dass sehr viele leute mit das ist eine
form des protests die sicherlich
gewalttätig ist die aber auch leute
aufwirbelt und tv anliegen den leuten
die gegend wo die not gegen diesen krieg
stehen das signal gibt es gibt andere es
gibt leute die gegen diesen krieg etwas
unternehmen wollen die militärischen
auswirkungen sind sehr schwer
einzuschätzen klar ist aber die
eisenbahnen sind gut gewählt ist hier
sind die russischen streitkräfte sind
von der eisenbahn abhängig und ein grund
warum sie bei kiew nicht erfolgreich
waren mann der das die eisenbahnstation
zu weit weg war was ich sehr interessant
finde und das spricht ja dafür dass die
menschen sich austauschen ist dass diese
form der sabotage an eisenbahnschienen
sehr stark zunächst in beta bus zu
beobachten war weder russische
mitarbeiter teilweise sogar der
eisenbahngesellschaft verhindern wollten
dass von billa russischen territorium
russische waffen die ukraine angreifen
und das haben andere offensichtlich
gesehen und beobachtet und versuchen das
jetzt auch anzuwenden
also sie sehen schon da gibt es im
untergrund möglichkeiten sich
auszutauschen und voneinander zu werden
verlange ich hab's ja eingangs gesagt
sie sind russland experte und auch
blogger und in dem zusammenhang sie
mitte juli geschrieben dass der krieg in
eine neue phase eingetreten sei und dass
die ukraine noch diesen sommer die
oberhand gewinnen könne was muss dafür
aus ihrer sicht passieren
naja die
großen haben jetzt glaube ich
unterschiedliche dinge versucht um in
der ukraine voranzukommen sie sind in
bezug auf kiew und rief gescheitert
haben dann ein schwerpunkt gewählt in
dombach und sind da in den letzten 80
tagen etwa 50 kilometer vorangekommen
das ist jetzt um das zu sagen ich
besonders beeindruckend was die
militärische leistungsfähigkeit
russlands betrifft es gibt anzeichen
dafür dass der russische angriffen nicht
nur langsam sondern sogar zum stehen
kommt und dann gibt es für die ukraine
die chance das momentum zu gewinnen und
gegen angriffe zu starten und eroberte
gebiete wieder zurückzugewinnen aber
dafür braucht die ukraine nicht nur die
artillerie und die heimat raketenwerfer
diese jetzt hat die ganz offensichtlich
helfen sollen sie braucht auch mehr
gepanzerte fahrzeuge vor allen dingen
wenn sie müssen sich vorstellen wenn
dort viele stunden lang mit artillerie
geschossen wird und sie haben keine
gepanzerten fahrzeuge um die soldaten zu
transportieren dann werden viele
soldaten verletzt oder sogar getötet
weil sie von splittern und schrapnell
getroffen werden ich glaube da braucht
die ukraine ganz dringend mehr
unterstützung und auch schnellere
unterstützung was gepanzerte fahrzeuge
angeht polen hat er viele kampfpanzer
geliefert die sicherlich helfen werden
aber auch da die ukraine ist ein sehr
sehr großes land im süden der ukraine
haben wir eine sehr große steppe ein
großes gebiet da braucht man für ihre
kampfpanzer viele gepanzerte fahrzeuge
und auch flugabwehr um eine übermacht
herzustellen um dann einen gegenangriff
gegen die russen zu starten in den
letzten tagen haben wir gesehen dass die
ukraine bestimmte brücken angegriffen
haben das kann ein zeichen für die
vorbereitung eines ukrainischen angriffs
seien es können auch ablenkungsmanöver
sein aber man sieht daran es ist nicht
nur russland das diktiert was geschieht
und die ukraine müssen reagieren die
lage ändert und die ukraine stärker in
die position selbst die initiative zu
haben verlange ich danke ihnen sehr für
ihre analyse und ihre informationen und
wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen abend
und
ich möchte noch einen letzten kommentar
von andrea müller vorlesen die schreibt
und spannender bericht danke wir danken
das freut uns sehr und bedanken uns auch
ganz herzlich für die vielen fragen und
kommentare und wünschen ihnen und euch
ebenfalls noch einen schönen abend bis
bald